flip a switch in this mouse's brain and
he'll change from a mild-mannered rodent
to an attack animal by activating
specific nerve cells using light
researchers are mapping the connections
in the brain that power these outbursts
many of the same threats that get a rise
out of humans provoke mice male mice
will defend their territory from
intruders
females defend their young
scientists are studying the nerve
signals that fuel these conflicts as
part of a larger effort to untangle how
the brain is wired for aggression in
mice flies and ultimately humans
such work points to a bundle of nerve
cells that regulate basic but seemingly
unrelated drives such as mating and
aggression these neurons reside within
the hypothalamus a region in the center
of the brain thanks to new genetic tools
researchers have identified a hotspot
for Rage within this region it's called
the ventral lateral area of the
ventromedial hypothalamus or bmh BL for
short another aggression zone sits in
the nearby medial amygdala understanding
how these neuron clusters connect to
each other and other areas of the brain
could reveal whether aggression networks
are widespread or centralized
researchers are looking at aggression
and other creatures as well in male
fruit flies a similar network of neurons
can provoke a fight over food or females
whether you're a fly or a mouse rage
networks may be wired differently in
males and females but across the animal
kingdom sex and violence seem to be
closely linked in fact some of the same
nerve cells that drive mice to fight
might also drive them to mate
digging into the roots of aggression
could also help explain and perhaps one
day control violent behaviors in humans